je voudrais rendre hommage à l'un des
invités les plus brillants et des plus
élégants qu'il m'ait été donné de
recevoir jean d'ormesson long
si tu nous regardes
alors jean d'ormesson quand je vais
inviter dans bain de minuit on m'a dit
pourquoi m'inviter vous oui vous dire
pourquoi parce que vous respirez la
gaieté vous avez des yeux qui pétillent
vous ne pensez pas vous faites partie
d'une espèce en voie de disparition
tiers des gens travaillent beaucoup mais
qui donne toujours comme ça à
l'impression d'une certaine facilité de
c'est toujours à l'aise je vous ai vus
arriver tout à l'heure vous êtes à
l'aise vous entretenez avec tout le
monde vous êtes star dans les dîners en
ville parce qu'il est brillant et
cultivé je pensais pas que des gens
comme vous il ya de moins en moins tabou
les médias je travaille beaucoup je suis
sûr vous travaillez j'ai longtemps fait
croire que je ne travaillais pas
beaucoup maintenant c'est presque
difficile de faire croire que je ne
travaille pas beaucoup parce qu'on ne
voit plus beaucoup dans les dîners en
ville il ya les cocktails parce que je
travaille et le week-end le samedi non
évidemment je travaille je suis pas si
les résultats sont à la hauteur du
travail mais en tout cas je travaille il
fera un petit reproche pour que louis
pauwels il faisait moins bien que vous
laissez arctique sont pas mal écrit le
mouvement est soit très très très bien
ces jours ci avec les miens sont pas
bien écrit je trouve que c'est un peu
moins bien que le livre vous donner
autant de mal que lui pour faire vos
papiers du figaro magazine je ne sais
pas en tout cas c'est vrai que j'ai fait
de mon mieux ouais mais c'est vrai que
j'attache plus important support sony
vend 8 nouveaux articles quand on lui en
parle et 10 mois chaque semaine je suis
une page de livre le figaro magazine
c'est vrai alors que vous me semble ça
un peu plus d'autres accords
un peu plus les affaires doit faire un
effort je peux me permettre vous allez à
georges tâche at il dit vous êtes super
brillant nul n'en disconvient
mais on se demande finalement cela de
votre brillante vd les convictions
profondes présent peut-être catholique
je suis catholique le pape à condamner
l'apartheid vous le savez le tac est ce
que vous faites entre la situation de
l'afrique du sud se situe avec mon autre
parent telle qu'est ce que vous faites
quand on apporte alors je vous dis à des
beurres
j'ai joué bien que ça commençait à peu
trop bien joli ça va maintenant
vous avez tout à fait raison alors je
dois vous dire que quand j'ai été
nommé directeur du figaro in des acteurs
et yao très moyrand a fait un petit
discours en trois points oui il ya dix
d'abord pardonnez moi il est d'abord il
est très intelligent voter pour lui
deuxièmement il est d'une ignorance
encyclopédie bastareaud lui avait dû
voter pour lui et troisièmement et c'est
ce que je dis il a des convictions très
ferme mais extrêmement tac c'est très
commode voter pour lui j'étais alors
c'est vrai que je ne suis pas libre
c'est un peu pareil sur le racisme le
pape à condamner le racisme qu'est ce
qui nous fait contre le refus tout à
fait contre le racisme vous faites quoi
je sais quoi parce que chateaubriand lui
il avait la duchesse de berry se désole
du mal à la candélie à prague je vais
vous dire ce que je sais comment les
fonctionnaires au magazine où vous
approuvez beaucoup
mon ami pour elle ce que nous avons
aussi beaucoup et bien je suis un des
rares à m élevé avec autant de force
contre le père
si vous trouvez que c'est pas quelque
chose de bien de s'élever contre le pen
dans le figaro magazine et bien
maintenant tout le monde le fait mais
j'ai même reçu pas mal de lettres de
lecteurs trouvant que je t'ai dans le
figaro magazine bien la bouche vous
tomberiez amoureux d'une petite bird une
beurette moi oui
si elle ne plaisait oui sans aucun doute
je vois pas de même elles font dans
l'ombre le problème je crois aussi que
je les écris et que j'ai écrit que si ma
fille tombée amoureuse d'un noir et ben
je serais tout à fait à chanter qu'elle
dépose à condition naturellement qu'ils
tiennent président de la république qui
soit frank sinatra ben parce qu'il faut
pas être vous aider la même entreprise
là vous avez à les plans aussi ils ont
une âme bien sûr alors voilà il faut
prendre ce qu'il ya de mieux partout et
naturellement il fait bon nombre de
différences entre un blanc jaune et aloi
je fais quand même une différence entre
un jour et un blanche contre les autres
sont plus intelligents pardonnez moi
d'être raciste mais je crains tu les
jaunes fois plus intelligent que les
blogs vous avez écrit quelque chose moi
qui m'a beaucoup touché parce que je
pensais un peu la même chose saint-just
si un jour je me retrouve en prison ce
sera génial parce que moi je pourrais
écrire des livres à condition
naturellement qu'on montre est bien
qu'on m'envoie on en voit comment vous
l'appelez une beurette où il a tout de
suite leur aide comme en voit une
barrette et qu'on traite bien j'ai un
bon lit que j'ai trois manches et se met
à l'aise dit ouais j'aurais qui enchante
et 10 ans à la bastille vous faire chez
elle à lorgues et académicien français
oui alors évidemment je vous faire une
interview proust express est ce que
souvent projection l'interview de
bernard pivot mais en fait c'est le
questionnaire de proust simplement je
vais vous demander c'est très important
de répondre en faisant des fautes de
français comme vous et académicien en
dessous des fautes de français au bois
sans rien n'est plus facile sera par
exemple si je vous dis vous fait couper
les cheveux tous les combien vous me
répondez je vais au coiffeur une fois
par mois d'accord d'accord coiffeur une
fois le mois on ne bouge pas pendant le
dîner gauche pendant le single
[Applaudissements]
bien vous êtes prêts toujours très bien
alors
quel est pour vous le comble drenthe
bien trop quel est pour vous le comble
de la misère le compte de la mise à oui
alors
c'est les fautes téléphone
pour lui dire je je je je je qu'aussi
bien ouais je crois aussi bien mais
voulait souffler si vous voulez
aider moi mais je suis sûr vous parlez
de très très bien alors le compte de la
misère
traité que plaisir
était que hélas
vous aider
je vois bien qu'il fait un effort
quotidien
alors le compte de la lozère le compte
de la misère c'est de ça ce fait est que
ça se répète
bg sa mère non mais vous êtes s'arrêter
que baiser sa mère de
jean d'ormesson votre idéal de bonheur
terrestre
vers prendre ça serait démarrer un roman
démarrer un faux bond
la faute pour laquelle vous avez le plus
d'indulgence
les gens qui causent pas bien
votre qualité préféré chez l'homme
de bas
ces camps et sentais
mieux ce serait là lucas l'académie je
pense qu'il devrait rentrer rémy ce sera
un exemple bien sûr alors il faut pas
s'habiller en rouge voilà votre qualité
préféré chez la femme
l'unige hocini misogynie lepage je vous
ai mises par exemple avec le préfet et
la femme c'est camus ce qui me plaisent
bien
c'est dieu pour vous de faire défaut oui
si du principal défaut facile ça
cette cause est tellement bien ce que
vous détestez par dessus tout
la musique qui font rares eu le don de
la nature que vous aimeriez avoir
la rapidité par exemple
france un peu excusez moi c'est
tellement non j'ai très bien c'est très
bien j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais
être comme moi à mon âge
à servion jugement dernier
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson
un tu utilisé sa notoriété pour séduire
je crois que me celui-ci à vis des
femmes ouais pour être connu ouais et
ensuite je me suis servi ce que j'étais
connu pour avoir des femmes à jean
d'ormesson as-tu consommé des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas pas suffisamment
jean d'ormesson as-tu pêcher en
accomplissant l'acte d'amour sans
volonté de procréer
d'accord
jean d'ormesson as tu envie d'une jeune
cousine
secret défense
jean d'ormesson
as-tu plus durant son existence à la
communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu oui
comment je me rappelle que
les y raconte on entre nous chacun
d'entre nous
alors moi je ne voulais pas ruiner d'un
coup tout le capital de sympathie que je
me suis attirée je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup
plus à les homosexuels qui ont été les
amis très chers à moi que j'ai beaucoup
aimé et quelquefois j'ai été obligé de
courir un peu dans la salle de bain
et autour de nous autant de la cuisine
jean d'ormesson as tu regardé tf1 le
samedi soir
il m'est même arrivé le regarder
thalassa il est arrivé le tout regarder
jean d'ormesson
as tu déjà eu envie de te suicider
je me suis toujours arrêter le monde sur
cette pente parce que je pense que le
suicide ratée est une chose très
ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr je teste menti j'en appelle
à l'assistance l'enfer ou le paradis
parfait
moi je vais vous dire un truc gens tout
simplement quand on vous voit ça donne
envie d'être vieux
c'est vraiment
c'est un bonheur c'est un bonheur il y
en a plus des gens comme
vous êtes immortel à deux titres d'abord
parce que vous êtes à l'académie
française et ensuite parce que votre nom
est tatoué sur l'épaule de julien doré
donc votre nom survivra
inéluctablement avait voulu je ferais
plutôt confiance à l'épaule de tenue
et vous savez la définition des
académiciens par jules renard que j'aime
beaucoup le commun des mortels peut bien
c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
les scorpions ont envie partir en
vacances avec lui parce que toute la
journée comme ça il doit raconter des
histoires c'est formidable alors bon les
thèmes habituels de d'ormesson
évidemment la vie la mort les femmes la
littérature est toujours cette
interrogation taraudante que vais-je
laisser que vais-je faire avant de
mourir vous savez c'est d'abord à un
écrivain doit faire attention à tout ce
qu'il écrit il doit faire attention à
tout ce qui dit et il doit faire
attention à la façon dont ils meurent
vous savez c'est très mauvais pour un
écrivain de mourir par exemple en même
temps que pia oui mais c'est ce qui est
arrivé à cocteau n'y a pas pris toute la
lumière pour elle parlait beaucoup de
cocteau il ya un autre écrivain qg
succéder à l'académie qui est jules
romain jules romains est mort le 14 ou
ses désastreuses mourut il faut faire
attention à ce que le 15 ou le monde
s'en foutait absolument alors vous
plaignez beaucoup quand même ne pas être
montaigne ou chateaubriand et vous êtes
finalement que le monsieur du figaro et
ça vous désespère ça
et encore les gens savent pas que votre
vraiment c'est jean lefebvre
pourtant j'ai bien que les répéter
souvent dans tous les cas voilà alors en
fait le problème vous dit j'étais trop
peureux pour être un grand écrivain
m il ya une définition de la littérature
que j'aime bien c'est du chagrin corrigé
par l'orthographe c'est un peu ça si ça
doit être un peu comme quand on écrit
les chansons non je crains corrigé par
l'alcool finalement
votre problème fondamentalement en fait
vous dites je ne serai jamais l'homme
d'un seul livre
ce que ce qui me faisait envie c'est
savez ce ces grands écrivains qui
attachent leur nom un livre au maire
avec il y adeux montaigne accusés c'est
cervantes avec don quichotte route avec
la recherche du temps perdu allons-y
voilà ça ça représente quelque chose
alors gens vous êtes de l'académie
française notre ami a commencé dans la
vie en postulant pour la star academy
c'est le jour idéal pour un academy quiz
[Musique]
il faut supporter nico chaque semaine
cette académie star academy il faut
supporter giscard chaque semaine or je
le supporte très bien ah mais
c'est vrai nous entendez bien avec lui
en tout cas c'est un excellente
académiciens il vient à l'académie
probablement plus souvent jours ouais
alors il ya une vieille très mal peigné
academy à khénifra demi française à
l'académie française jean n'a pas non et
bien peignés carrère d'encausse
mais la star academy oui il ya une
vieille très mal peigné ils demandent
toutes les journées à ça alors la qualif
ans
je ne dis pas ça par mes dix ans par
time il ya une histoire célèbres ou à un
moment donné le directeur que président
il dit si ces messieurs qui bavardent
faisaient comme ces messieurs qui
dorment ça ces messieurs qui écoutent
pourrez entendre ces messieurs qui
parlera souvient elle
ces classes l'académie française
quand on sort tu es mort l'académie
française où va se faire academy dès
2002 le bravo
[Applaudissements]
laurent fabius en est fan
le nom
biaggi qui l'adoré la star academy un
jour où il voulait faire jeunes dans une
interview celle interne musée qui
mangeaient les carottes râpées emile
zola ne l'a jamais fait
je crois qu'il s'est présenté 18 h dans
la tempe ils n'ont pas pris et la star
ac non plus
jean loup dabadie nakhal at-il fait les
deux les deux bravo
qu'il a fait la star academy avec les
chansons de julien clerc et l'académie
française je voulais rentrer d'occasion
vous donner des noms de gens qui l'ont
fait aucune des deux mais
ça fait partie du patrimoine français
les deux les deux bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le prix nobel de la connerie à qui on
pourrait le de mort on va encore me
reprocher ça mais je suis candidat au
nom d'une pâle fort je suis candidat le
belge un choc dit j'étais un jeune con
maintenant je suis un vieux mais arrêtez
de vous déplacer parce qu'il est en
route pour la sainteté oman oui c'est
vrai
deux auteurs il est un pur esprit
maintenant il est en montgolfière on
veut pas me
jean d'ormesson bonsoir très heureux de
vous avoir avec nous vous êtes ici ce
soir pour nous confirmer que apparemment
vous seriez le seul immortel vraiment
immortel contrairement aux autres vous
connaissez la définition de cocteau
sommes immortel pour la durée de notre
vie après nous nous changeons en
fauteuil
d'ailleurs vous avez été élu le mec le
mieux conservé pour son âge par les
lectrices de elle bravo jans
évident il ya l'aide qu'est-ce qui vous
voudriez qu'on dise de vous dans 100 ans
ouais et répondait je voudrais qu'on
dise il n'est pas mal pour son argent
qu'elle tue en son nom mais sans cette
année dionne la télévision jours alors
ce qui est incroyable avec vous donc
vous et 84 ans vous êtes toujours dans
le coup récemment je lisais dans le
magazine lire et dans l'express jandaud
la nouvelle idole des jeunes rémois
abidjan
alors il disait loin de se ringardiser
le stendhalien est devenue une icône la
première pop star en costume planel
extraordinaire quelle chance alors on va
vous poser la question que tout le monde
se pose
qui ne vous aiment pas il ya des gens
qui me qui m'aime pas et même que me
déteste ce qui assez que je ne déteste
personne oui j'ai remarqué que ceux qui
fatigué et ceux qui viennent dit c'est
c'est de détester
mémoire est content
alors
bien sûr sur les 84 ans et vous avez
déclaré récemment je suis vieux j'ai
commencé à comprendre que j'étais vieux
à partir du moment où les gens m'ont dit
comme vous êtes jeune vous avez badeni
j'ai remarqué que quand j'étais jeune
c'était très rare quand j'étais jeune
qu'on me dise comme vous avez 1000 oui
on dit quand vous avez bonne huile comme
vous êtes jeune ça ça met la puce à
l'oreille ouais est ce que pour finir
vous pourriez nous faire votre fameux
formidable je veux bien faire formidable
mais je fais plutôt épatant ah oui les
partants certains
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu